[Music]
couple of seconds delay here Thomas
actually this is the official feed we're
looking at as a cosmic girl as this
repurposed Boeing 747 is called launches
into the night sky
[Music]
to open space for everyone
and Thomas for anyone who tuned in
expecting a rocket launch and sees a
plane take off this is just stage one
isn't it
yes it is to be honest if you didn't
know better that could just look like a
holidays yet couldn't it and yet there
was this enormous rocket strapped
underneath its wing as it heads off
towards the south of Ireland and he is
doing the heavy lifting aircraft of
course are brilliant at getting to
around 35 000 feet extremely efficiently
it's the densest part of the atmosphere
but those wings help lift that uh heavy
cargo to an altitude and from that point
the the aircraft the rocket can take
over and because it's much thinner
atmosphere up there it can then use much
less fuel to get to space and it is one
of the efficiencies that there are
transforming the space industry bringing
down launch costs to a few thousand
pounds and enabling companies to get a
lot more Hardware into space which of
course is transforming all our lives
back down here on planet Earth